[Music]
justin tucker for the winner from 49
yards snap is good kicking away it is
long enough
and the kick is good the time has come
off the clock the haze in the barn and
the ravens take down the 49ers
and this house is on fire
and thanksgiving weekend and baltimore
ends with one more thing to be thankful
for
every cliche possible jammed into the
call there as there were a little i
don't know a little more organic
excitement not the reading off the i'm
sorry i shouldn't be critical but it
just felt like the guy's reading off the
list of cliches well yeah it didn't feel
real it did not feel real i i agree yes
it did feel forward i'm glad i'm not the
only one no it did it felt a little
forced there but uh that was an awesome
game either way i was a little
disappointed at rain i can't lie for
that game i thought that took away from
it yeah it did it took away from the
greatness of the game but either way the
difference in the game was once again
number eight lamar jackson i mean i
really think it was two even teams
slugging it out and his ability to kind
of control the clock in certain big
situations with runs he made
really was the difference in the game i
mean i i think it was a very evenly
played football game both physical like
i said i do think the rain hurt the
49ers just because of
more than the ravens because the ravens
are more size oriented the 49ers have a
little bit more of a speed element to
their overall team i know the ravens
have lamar jackson and all that uh and
of course their boots and play action
pass game i think is limited in that
kind of weather but either way i do
think there's still a good chance that's
a super bowl preview by the way it's uh
pro football talk monday edition he's
chris sims i'm mike florio nbc sports
radio and i think they know hello to our
friends they've tuned in you never know
this could be for the one person out
there right this is the first day that
they see it on their guy yeah they say
oh what's this let's see what they saw
it on their guide do they have to hear
you saying that
but they pop well maybe they don't maybe
they just trip across it maybe they're
channel surfing and they're like oh i
wonder what this show is and we talked
for 10 minutes without telling them well
maybe they were watching and they were
going man they're having a good
conversation why did this idiot stop
this i just wanted my channel i turned
it on when i saw it on my guide in the
name of the show and the channel anyway
there's a radio audience as well right
there they may want to i was wondering
why you were sitting there so quietly i
was just waiting for you to finish
hogging the microphone so i could make
the point of what the show is called
don't ask me about
six minutes and 28 seconds yeah that's
how long the ravens held it tied 17 to
get in position for the game-winning
field goal controlling the clock and you
can do that when you have a quarterback
who also is a running back yeah you got
kyle said it last week and this isn't
disrespectful lamar jackson it's reality
when he decides to run he becomes a
running back he's not a running
quarterback because he doesn't look to
throw he doesn't look to dive right he
doesn't look to slide he doesn't look to
get out of bounds he just looks to run
he becomes a guy
who is no different than the guy that
you would hand the ball to and say go no
that's who he is i agree 101 yards on
the ground 105 yards through the air his
fifth career double triple this is a
stat that mds from pft
weeks ago and he has five now for his
career the record all time is eight for
mike vick lamar jackson has four this
season alone it's incredible what he's
doing and he's currently second time
second place all time with five it just
shows you how rare it is that this
happens but lamar jackson gets another
one yesterday and the ravens get the win
i do want to see a rematch yeah right
right all due respect to the other teams
that are in the playoff field and would
like to get to the super bowl i want to
see this one again it had that feel to
it of a special game it did and i would
like to see it on a neutral site right
where weather isn't an issue thank you
you can't wind up about the day but you
got to admit though the rain kind of
took away from it too it does it makes
it makes it a little bit of a slop fest
it makes conservative play calling too
in certain situations isn't it funny how
we love snow right but we hate rain yeah
yeah i know you're right well rain i
think really affects the passing game a
lot more than snow snow as long as it's
not like just a total wind gust type
blizzard you can throw in the snow it
actually a lot of the times my
experience when it snows it actually
feels better the football it gives it a
little bit of a moisture to where you
can really grip it but i mean you said
it lamar jackson i think if you really
just boiled that game down you know it
was pretty even up front uh there was a
you know on both sides of the ball
offense and defensive line and then his
ability to run out the clock or you know
keep the defense honest because ooh he
might keep it around the edge oh there's
mark ingram up the middle for three or
four yards to control the clock i mean
they can just beat you so many different
ways because of his skill and talent and
of course he's just continues to throw
the ball well too even though it wasn't
a lot yesterday it was effective and he
had a big touchdown pass felt like the
turning point in the game came when
marcel harris to the 49ers a backup
safety ripped the ball out of jackson's
possession and recovered it right in
kind of one
cobra strike it happened so fast the
first loss fumble of the season for
lamar jackson which is amazing when you
consider how much he runs the football
but that felt like the the moment where
the opening was gonna be there for the
ravens yeah because the ravens are up
17-14 they're driving they're going in
here and the 49ers get it back and they
eventually tie it up and it just felt
like that that that was going to be that
thing that we look back to and say
that's when the 49ers secured their
opportunity to win the game but the
ravens just kept it going and there's
that there's that hit out of bounds that
was initially called right a penalty
they picked the flag up this is the one
big gripe that i have and a lot of
others have when a quarterback decides
to become a running back he's a running
back all protections are off except for
the you know lowering the helmet yeah
right so there's a weapon and that
applies running back as well right but
there was a play in the cowboys game on
thursday where dak prescott got hit late
no running back ever draws that flag it
was not the kind of late hit for a
running back that draws a flag that hit
out of bounds we see running backs hit
like that all the time it doesn't draw a
flag so we we we have to get to the
point where if the if the teams are
going to take advantage of quarterbacks
running the ball they have to accept the
fact that the quarterbacks become
running backs and they lose all their
yeah well quarterbacks for some reason
even the running ones seem like they
want the grace period of like hey i'm
going out of bounds but i'm not there
yet so you shouldn't hit me no no no no
no no when they pull up they run
we talked about it last week we've seen
a lot of quarterbacks pulled the okie
doke and get a bunch of extra yards yes
you're exactly right but i think uh you
know they're there you mentioned the
turning point right i mean you're right
at that point of the game it looked like
the ravens were kind of like oh gosh
here they're going to control the game
they're going to go up by 10 points it
looks like and will the 49ers be able to
come back from that but you know early
on in the game i really thought san
francisco had uh uh was was in kind of a
controlling the game up seven nothing
and then of course that strip sack
fumble and i can't remember exactly who
got it i'm gonna try to pull brandon
williams he's the one that got it coming
off the edge there to me that was
another big turning point to where i
went oh the 49ers looked like the better
team early on then it went ooh
the ravens
got control of this and really i felt
like they had control of it ever since
that point and you're right with the
strip sack or the strip i thought oh
maybe the 49ers will bring it back but
it still seemed like the ravens had
control of the game when all said and
done down the stretch yeah and look the
ravens were at home the weather was an
issue the 49ers probably would have won
that game if they played it in san
francisco who knows right
here's what i like about baltimore about
what what happened yesterday it had been
coming so easily for them in recent
weeks i think they needed one like this
i think john harbaugh needed one where
hey we get the win but also
i have plenty of meat that i can use to
to fashion coaching points and and we we
need to work on this we need to work on
that because i i think if it's too easy
for you in the regular season and you
get to a tough hard-fought playoff game
you don't have that that memory bank to
draw upon of being in a game like this
is going to help both of these teams
yeah when they get to the postseason if
they're in a tough grounded out game
because they've been in a tough grounded
out game that felt like a playoff game
yeah battle tested definitely you know
you're playing one of the best teams in
football that's going to give you
confidence to go okay well you know we
slugged it out with them and maybe
didn't play our best and still found a
way to win the football game i think the
other thing that's going to give
baltimore you know a lot of confidence
too is just come play off time no matter
what the weather conditions you know it
just was another thing to say oh it's
rainy and sloppy oh okay well we'll just
overpower you and lamar will keep the
ball and yeah you guys are trying to
figure out which way he's going and
slipping in the grass and the mud and
all that well he knows which way he is
going and uh you know i think there's
that element too that you know it
doesn't matter what happens in january
if they get some bad weather games there
that they're going to be fine as well
you know the 49ers need one of these
tough grinded out games that they
actually win yeah their two most
exciting games this year
49ers seahawks three weeks ago and
ravens 49ers yesterday the 49ers lost
right you want you want to win you want
to have a game like that that you you
can sense it's a special game you can
sense it's a big moment and you emerge
with the victory you don't you don't
want to be constantly failing in that
setting because there's going to be some
tough tests for both of these teams and
there's another tough test for the 49ers
coming up and don't look now but they
may be the five seed tomorrow morning
yeah because if the seahawks the vikings
tonight there goes that lead that they
so carefully built and meticulously
constructed one week after another all
those wins because they lost to the
seahawks and the seahawks have been
great this year they could tumble down
to the five seed and they go to new
orleans next week to play the saints and
the saints have a couple few i look i
think the 49ers can beat the saints i
think the 49ers have a better team this
year i do too i do too but but they're
playing that game in new orleans yeah
that's going to be a factor no no
question but i mean to your point yeah
they could be the fifth seed uh but they
have total control over this situation i
mean here down the stretch you know they
got the saints they can knock them out
the way last week of the last week of
the seasons the seahawks you know so and
the seahawks still have a pretty tough
schedule themselves too i mean tonight's
not going to be just some cupcake
against your minnesota vikings they got
the rams left on their schedule who kind
of found their mojo back again boy they
sure did yeah they sure did and uh you
know i think there's a lot of football
here to be played still before this
thing is all said and done but i'm with
you i still favor the 49ers as being the
best team in the nfc uh but it's it's uh
it's not by a big margin over the other
two as far as the saints and the
seahawks and and the other thing i've
been saying all day after tonight
there's still 25 of the season to be
played and a lot can happen yeah 64
regular season games a lot of playoff
spots on the line playoff seeding still
to be determined it's going to be a fun
finish to the season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports